jennifer lopez and ben affleck spend
some quality time with her daughter emmy
the trio enjoyed dinner together in los
angeles at hot spot craigs where a
source tells et they had a fun family
night out i'm thrilled i'm really happy
et source says they entered and left
through the back exit and sat towards
the back of the restaurant in a more
secluded area quote everyone was getting
along bonding j.lo was super sweet to
the staff and craig's is one of her
favorite spots they all seemed happy to
be there i can't stop smiling earlier
this week the couple was spotted taking
a tour of an estate in toluca lake
california which used to belong to the
late bob hope and his wife dolores
before heading to beverly hills to check
out an 85 million dollar mansion
complete with 12 bedrooms stunning views
and enough parking to fit 80. you heard
me
80 cars i do love that safe to say there
would be plenty of room in that house to
do even more family bonding it feels
really good and it's really nice but i'm
so happy of course jen shares 13 year
old twins max and emmy with her
ex-husband mark anthony while the 48
year old actor shares 15 year old violet
12 year old seraphina and nine-year-old
samuel with his ex-wife jennifer garner
and while the pair searches for their
dream home a source told et last month
that their friends wouldn't be surprised
if they quote ultimately end up together
this is a thrill
and as their rekindled romance continues
to heat up a source told et in july that
the relationship is serious pointing out
their on another level chemistry quote
this time around however they both
really feel like this is it
the two were engaged from 2002 to 2004
and got back together this year after
jen and alex rodriguez called it quits
et source adds that everything feels 100
natural with them once they rekindled it
was like no time had passed
[Music]